this is the Dell Latitude 2100 so this
is the Dell Latitude 2100 much my friend
Andrew here just said it's got it some
netbooks it's cost 550 bucks it's got
the standard netbook specs so it has an
atom processor in it one gigabyte of RAM
but also have some other features on it
that makes this suitable for students so
it's got this sort of rubberized
exterior that repels dirt and grime and
chocolate and other nasty stuff it's got
a touch compatible screen on the front
so you can actually you know use your
finger to navigate around and it also
has this little this light on the back
that flickers supposedly when you're
online so if you're cruising the
internet when you're not supposed to be
your teacher can can can bust you for it
you can get kicked out of school and get
kicked out of school so andrew like
what's your favorite points of this
computer like what what excites you the
most about it I love the feel of the
front pretty awesome this I like this
because kids always try to take stuff
and then say if there is if they have
the exact same thing well this you can
put your nametag cool and the so okay
what about the keypad like most netbooks
have like keep has they're too small
even for like my hands and my hands are
pretty small would you think about I
think this is awesome like it's just as
big as my laptop at home screen is
touchscreen which i think is I mean I
like touchscreens but if it's meant for
kids that might not be good because they
have crappy fingers yes yes well that's
yeah I would take that out or if they're
gonna keep that I would put some kind of
protection on it like screening like and
then the mousepad is I think well what
rating would you give this guy I have 10
out of 10 balls yes yes um
I give it seven seven balls some blue
balls out of ten balls okay well we
actually gave it an eight but I think
between seven and eight that's pretty
that's a pretty good rate